♪ ♪ ♪
- L'exposition "Lemoyne.
Hors jeu" est la plus importante
rétrospective consacrée
à ce jour à l'artiste québécois
hors norme qu'est Serge Lemoyne.
JEAN-LUC MURRAY, dg, Musée
national des beaux-arts du Qc
- Lemoyne a été dans
l'imaginaire très caractérisé
par sa série inspirée
des glorieux, des Canadiens,
dans les années 70.
- Parmi les oeuvres marquantes
de la période bleu-blanc-rouge
de Lemoyne exposées,
on retrouve les emblématiques
Dryden, Lafleur, Stardust
et Béliveau.
PAUL HOUDE, porte-parole,
exposition "Lemoyne. Hors jeu"
- Pendant 10 ans, Lemoyne a été
inspiré du bleu-blanc-rouge
et à l'époque, dites-vous
une chose, le bleu-blanc-rouge
était au maximum de sa gloire.
Le Canadien gagnait chaque année
la Coupe Stanley, ou presque.
- Près de 200 oeuvres et une
centaine de documents d'archives
illustrent les différentes
périodes d'une carrière
artistique qui s'étale
sur 40 ans, avec toujours cette
même quête de l'artiste d'abolir
les frontières entre l'art
et la vie.
- C'est présent toute sa
carrière et c'est ce qui a fait
qu'il a été un petit peu rejeté
par l'élite culturelle,
parce que lui considérait
que l'art comme le sport
devraient être dans notre vie
de tous les jours et c'est une
vision qu'on partage au musée,
c'est-à-dire que pas besoin
de connaître l'art pour aimer
l'art. C'est une expérience
d'abord humaine, émotive; ici,
dans ce cas-là, joyeuse.
- L'exposition vise un public
très large. Les visiteurs
pourront s'attarder devant le
masque mythique de Ken Dryden
en même temps qu'ils
découvriront un artiste engagé.
EVE-LYNE BEAUDRY, conservatrice
de l'art contemporain, MNBAQ
- On a choisi le titre "Lemoyne.
Hors jeu" et la définition
de hors jeu, c'est se mettre
dans une position interdite
par le jeu. C'est une personne
qui allait au-delà
des conventions esthétiques,
au-delà des conventions
muséales. Dans les années 60,
notamment, un artiste
iconoclaste qui travaillait
beaucoup avec le "happening",
beaucoup avec la participation
du public. C'est une personne
qui était très rassembleur.
- L'exposition "Lemoyne.
Hors jeu" sera présentée
jusqu'au 9 janvier
au Musée national des beaux-arts
du Québec.
Ici Valérie Cloutier,
Radio-Canada, Québe